somebody that wants to completely
transform who they are you have to
change your identity I'm the smart guy
and that's how I thought of myself and
then the life slapped me around and I
realized oh wow I'm really actually not
that smart I just grew up in a small
town I realized that I had been sort of
taken as a default value intelligence
maybe it was the family I grew up in or
the movies I watched I don't know and
then I realized oh I can actually change
that not everybody values themselves for
that and so I could swap that out with
something else I want people to
understand that those things that are
just deeply within you that seem as if
they are innate human qualities
challenge them all a lot of what you
value comes down to what you repeat and
so just repeating myself I'm the learner
I'm the learner I'm the learner it began
to be my identity and then rewarding
myself emotionally when I did that then
it's like through that repetition cycle
it actually starts to be meaningful the
year the learner and by the way I was
telling everybody I'm the learner I see
myself as a learner I'm the learner I'm
the learner and because I was telling
people then I really felt the sense of
congruence with wanting to act like the
learner and so when you say you're going
to do something and you do it you earn
self-credibility so now I've got this
Loop I said I was a learner here I am
reading this book here I am being
willing to admit when I'm wrong seeking
out knowledge looking for disconfirming
evidence like I get to feel good about
myself for that the biggest
stop living other people's version of
your life and to start actually feeling
happy and proud of yourself the biggest
hack to doing that is to figure out what
you stand for to figure out your single
most important core value I believe that
everybody has a single most important
core value and when you figure that out
it gives you a lot more clarity a lot
more Direction a lot more confidence and
allows you to start to to do things that
you never thought were possible all of a
sudden that idea that you've gone up oh
my gosh I could do this thing but then
never take an action on it things start
to happen for you because you have that
Clarity of value so I wrote two books on
this your one word and built to serve
and we go through the process of
figuring out your one word or your who
who are you what do you stand for what
is that single most important core value
one of my favorite activities that I go
through I call it the five essential
questions but the most important one
there I find usually is asking people
who is your favorite teacher growing up
and why
so if you've understood the concept of
hey I need I need to have a core value I
need to know what I stand for I'm tired
of being on on quicksand I'm tired of
living other people's version of my life
okay great how do I figure it out do I
just pick one at random do I just read a
book like how do I actually figure out
what I stand for well
asking yourself that question who your
favorite teacher growing up was and why
I think it's critical think about it
you've had how many teachers in your
life think about your school elementary
school high school uh University if you
went to a college other teachers you've
had
you've had lots of teachers growing up
and
chances are most of your teachers if you
walk past them on a street corner you
wouldn't recognize them That's how
little of an impact they've had on you
think about your high school teachers if
they walk past you right now you
wouldn't know who they were
because they had no impact
but there's always that one teacher that
stood out
there's one teacher that stood out for
you
why it wasn't because they taught you
grade 8 math
is because they made you feel different
as a human
they gave you something more than just a
subject matter they were teaching
and that gives you a clue why did you
like that teacher gives you a clue as to
who you are and what you want to spread
into other people so quick example my
favorite teacher growing up was Madame
Farr but I'm far was my grade 12 French
teacher and I didn't love her because
she taught me French I barely use French
and on a day-to-day basis
what she taught me was to believe in
myself
I was a BNC student going into my last
year of of uh
High School
and she would meet with me every week
before before school started once a week
we'd sit down we'd chat we'd talk about
life we talk about school we talk about
where I was at we talked about what's on
my mind
and in those conversations she made me
feel like I could I could do more
that I that her belief in me created
more belief in myself
and in that last year I went from being
a b and c student to straight 90s
straight A Plus
[Music]
I was still the same guy I still had the
same ability and the same Talent you
know she wasn't passing me the answers
to the test that I had
it was just that belief in me that she
gave me that allowed me to go off and
start to perform more
so I think that's the most important
question you can ask
another one you can look at is what was
your favorite movie growing up and why
so what's your favorite movie of all
time why there's so many movies that
you've watched most of them you don't
remember but there's one that that
sticks out that really stands out for
you in some in some way for some reason
my favorite movie is Seabiscuit it's
about this horse that is way too small
it's about this jockey that's way too
big it's about this owner that's
bankrupt and somehow they all find each
other and start winning a whole bunch of
races when when they they shouldn't be
you know and it's based off of a true
story and it ended up lifting a nation
that people love this Underdog Story and
it's a story of belief same thing
story of belief
we all at least for me I love the idea
of being that Seabiscuit or being the
jockey or being the owner
and helping not just each other believe
in themselves but also the nation
for the audience for the fans helping
them believe in themselves
and so if you started asking those
questions if you started thinking about
who are the people that make you come
alive that make you feel like you're a
better person and what are the resources
or what are the YouTube channels or
Instagram accounts or books or podcasts
or shows what are the things that have
made you come alive what are the things
that have made you feel
like you could do more
and then next to each one write down a
couple of words so your favorite teacher
growing up who was it and then why three
words to explain why your favorite movie
of all time
and then three words why and what you'll
find is as you do this exercise
you'll see some similar patterns you'll
see some words pop off the page you'll
see that same word come up a couple
times
that's your who
that's your single most important core
value
that's what you still need more of in
your life right now and that's what you
want to give to the world
the other great part about it is that
will be with you for life this isn't
something that we want to change this is
who you are this is your best version of
you
at my core I'm I'm the best when I
believe in myself and my biggest problem
is still I need to believe in myself
more to get to the next level
when you figure out your most important
core value your who your one word
oh what you need right now
my biggest challenge right now is that I
don't believe in myself to hit the next
level
and it's what you want to give to the
people around you if you're watching
this you're probably an entrepreneur you
want to you want to give to the world
you want to have a big mission you have
a big message
but some people like Nina who is just
here she doesn't have a big message but
she wants to help the closest people to
her
we all want to feel like what we do
matters we all want to feel like we're
having an impact on people whether the
closest people to us or to the world
but we're stuck and we're lost and we
need guidance and if you feel like you
have all these ideas but you don't know
how they all make sense
and you don't know that
you feel like it could be something but
you don't know how to get there
there's not enough momentum happening
is because you're not in touch with your
single most important core value
here's an example if I'm struggling to
do something I'm struggling to get on
stage to speak I'm struggling to turn on
the camera to make a video for you I'm
struggling to launch my next project you
know I get an idea and then I say oh God
I can't do that
what do I need
at the end of the day what do I really
need like what's the thing that's going
to turn that idea into actual action
I do more belief
and so when I can catch myself
procrastinating finding excuses saying
no when I shouldn't be I can quickly
reverse it by saying Evan you need to
believe more on yourself
because that's at the core of who I am
and when I can catch it then it gives me
the courage to go off and do it to
report the video to get on stage he
learns that project to say yes to say
yes to say yes I think of uh Alex who
helps me run Toronto dance salsa his who
was belong
he needs to belong more with himself and
he needs to spread more belong to the
world
and whenever he's not happy and whenever
he's not following through and whenever
he's not hitting his goals and doing the
work it's because he doesn't feel like
he belongs doesn't feel like he belongs
to himself and he doesn't feel like he's
spreading belong to the world if you are
slow
if you have all of this unrealized
potential inside you
thing that is missing
is you not following through on who you
say you want to be you're not matching
that potential
how you make it practical
to figure out your who
because every time you come back to that
you say I just need more of X I need
more hope I need more freedom I need
more belief I need more belong I need
more love I need more care for myself
and then to spread it to the world
and when you can feel that
when you can actually
it'll dramatically change how you show
up
all of a sudden now you're making
progress where you weren't before you're
accomplishing more in a day than you
were in a year
chains you've given yourself wings
you've given yourself the permission to
actually go off and do the scary thing
that's inside you because now you know
who you are
figure out your one word figure out your
who watch your life change also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
does a negative mindset have more
effects on Mental Health in the brain
and does it get easier to control your
emotions if you try long enough so first
of all yes a negative mindset is going
to have an overall impact on your mental
health so anxiety is the easiest one to
talk about because I've experienced it
but I think depression is also going to
be hugely affected by what you allow
yourself to repeat so one core mechanism
of the brain is to understand that while
we are a very active species that's
meant to go out and explore and master
our environment there's a secondary
evolutionary Force pushing on us which
is that we also want to conserve
calories to make sure that we survive
a famine so we have this dual competing
thing of wanting to go out and do cool
hence the Big Dreams and wanting to sit
on the couch and eat a bag of potato
chips hence why we procrastinate why we
feel lazy and the
way that the brain as a physiological
organ has dealt with this dual impulse
challenge over evolutionary time frames
is that it's a process called
myelination and what that does is it's
wrapping fatty tissue around neurons
that fire together at the same time
frequently so this is why they say
neurons that fire together wire together
they are literally getting optimized for
the efficient transmission of these
signals across those synaptic gaps and
the reason that they do this is that it
becomes easier from a caloric
perspective to do those things so now
you've made whatever you repeat whether
it's something empowering or
disempowering whether it's something
that makes you anxious or feel like you
can do anything it's going to make
thinking those thoughts and feeling
those feelings easier from a caloric
perspective it also begins to move it
into What's called the default mode
Network so the default mode network is
responsible for
anything that we'll call automatic
thinking if you've done something a
bazillion times you don't think about
brushing your teeth you just brush your
teeth you don't think about driving to
work oftentimes certainly before the
pandemic you just drive to work and
there were times where you would show up
at work and be like whoa I almost don't
remember the journey getting here and
the reason is that what ends up
happening is your cognition can be put
onto basically something else you're
thinking through daydreaming whatever
and the thing that you do in a
repetitive way is Just Happening
automatically super efficiently and it's
a thing that happens to the brain where
you can scan somebody and go up they're
in the default mode Network right now
and if worry anxiety Panic fear stress
if that's what you're doing all the time
then that's what's going to be moved
over made calorically easier to do moved
into the default mode Network so that by
default that's where you go and this is
where most people spend the majority of
their lives is living in that default
mode network of these emotions that
they've created these very well-worn
paths to looping around over and over to
feeling those feelings over and over and
so you can understand since the body
responds to your
the mental states that you're constantly
in that each of those mental States is
characterized by hormonal and
neurochemical states and the body will
have different long-term consequences
based on what you're feeling so for
instance if you are constantly stressed
or constantly anxious your cortisol
levels are extraordinarily High cortisol
levels begin to damage the um
the elasticity of your blood vessels is
one of the vectors of attack on your
body and so you don't want to stay in
these chronically elevated levels
because it deteriorates the Integrity of
the lining of your blood vessels and
this is the kind of thing that leads to
stroke or coronary heart disease so
being incredibly thoughtful not to loop
on those things which doesn't mean that
there aren't bad things going on in your
life but it does mean that when you
allow yourself to bloop that there is
this hormonal and chemical Cascade as a
response to that that your body will
have negative consequences to or
positive consequences if you're in a
loving calm State a lot and that's the
thing that becomes the default mode
Network that becomes the easiest thing
for you to think and you're in this
really calm and creative state a lot of
times then you're gonna prolong your
life there's a part in Fight Club and
the gift that I would like to give the
world if I had which I did not but if I
had sat down and sat in my tension for
you know what do I want to convey this
is one of my like top five things that I
want to get across to people if you
really want to succeed yeah there's a
moment in Fight Club where he puts his
hand out and the guy puts a caustic
Solution on the back of his hand and it
burns and he tells him that he has to
just leave it there and he ends up
holding his hand down so that he can't
take it away at first because it hurts
so badly and then finally he releases
and the guy has the strength to leave
his hand there and let it just burn
and what I'm saying is you have a
mechanism in your mind called the
psychological immune system its job is
get you to pull your hand away to wash
off the thing that burns and hey you're
fine again yeah what I'm saying is if
you want to be great
the burning sensation is you having to
accept that you something up that
you're not as good as you want to be
that there are people that are better
than you that you're not far as far
along in the journey as you want to be
and what you have to learn how to do if
you want to be great
you have to learn to let it burn and
even though your impulse is going to be
to turn away from that to not look at it
to soothe it by saying it's them it's
their fault they it up I grew
grow up in the wrong place it's fine for
them they're wealthy like whatever
excuse you use to
try to let yourself off the hook for not
being where you want to be instead of
saying actually the power is the ability
to let it burn and one of my employees
was just asking me yesterday and he said
how do you not get overwhelmed and I
said you want to know the God's honest
truth the second I feel that impulse
Brendan I say to myself
you don't get overwhelmed I'm I'm not
gonna back down I will not break you
cannot break me yeah that yeah get that
out of your head right now yeah and
just interrupting that thought with an
aggressive impulse of like yeah I'm
gonna let it burn yeah now I'm not a
so I immediately go hey thank you
psychology for letting me know that oh
there's a lot of things coming at me
right now yep so I'm gonna go meditate
but the way that I interrupt the thought
is by reminding myself not to be weak
who's in control right 100 who's in
control is overwhelming control or are
you in control they once gave me a list
there's like 750 000 keywords and I had
to comb through it in an Excel
spreadsheet and say either yes or no
that took days and days and days of Mind
numbing yes no yes no yes no yes no what
do you mean 750. this was back in like
so we had
um words that did we want to advertise
on did we want to advertise on these
keywords like so you would buy a list of
like powerful keywords on Google and
this is all CPC stuff so do we want to
show up on these keywords yes or no like
here's our business you know what we're
doing what keywords would we want to
show up on and so I'd have to go and
clean the list there's no way no AI to
comb through it for us so uh I would do
that so anything like that where I could
I just add value add value add value and
everyone starts gravitating towards a
person who's always upbeat great energy
and never says no and is always asking
how they can help it it is a Formula
that will win for all time and so that
was it and I just threw that that
intensity at it because every day I was
like I'm here to get rich I'm here to
get rich and when I get rich I'm gonna
go build my studio if you want to make a
change you have to change your vision of
Who You Are
you have to begin telling yourself a
different narrative and the narrative
you tell yourself about yourself is
everything and if you tell yourself that
you're a scared undereducated kid from
Tacoma whose family has never
accomplished anything let me tell you
what you will become
a scared undereducated kid from Tacoma
who never accomplishes anything because
that's what you believe
you tell yourself that story enough and
it will become real
but on the flip side you could tell
yourself a story of you're a learner you
learn faster than most people you're
willing to put in more work than most
people you're willing to read more books
than most people you're willing to spend
an inhuman amount of time every day
improving your mind simply by getting
new ideas into the system and that you
will admit that you're wrong faster than
anybody else that you won't let your ego
get in the way and you tell yourself
that story over and over and over so
when somebody comes and tells you how
stupid you are that you're just a dumb
kid from Tacoma you go you're right
that's amazing thank you for pointing
out that flaw because now that I'm aware
of it I can improve it because I'm the
learner
and once I switched my narrative to
being the learner it didn't matter where
I started it only mattered where I was
trying to go and as long as I had that
Clarity then I could execute because I
believed I could do anything I set my
mind to without limitation when you look
at somebody with money especially when
you don't have it you admire them and so
you think if I had money I would admire
myself but it doesn't work like that so
once you get the money the thing you
thought would happen to yourself the
story about who you are you think is
going to change and it doesn't so that's
when people become totally disillusioned
they think if I have the Ferrari I'll
think differently about myself if I have
the house I'll think differently about
myself your insecurities are coming with
you wherever you go so if you think
anything external is going to change
that the only thing that changes your
insecurities show up in the gym put in
the effort go to work do the things
suffer in service of somebody else do
something to bring beautiful things to
people that you love and care about do
something beautiful to bring something
to somebody you've never even met those
things will change your story for eight
and a half years I'm doing that I am
working seven days a week ignoring my
wife at about the six and a half year
mark my wife pulls me aside and says
you're now damaging our marriage and I'm
not willing to continue like this
so I was like all right something's got
to give and that forced me to really
look and say I'm profoundly unhappy and
showing up every day chasing money just
isn't actually who I am and I need to do
something that makes me feel alive in
the moment
so it ends up being a cool part of my
story but what I want people to know is
when the following thing happened I was
a wash in shame and so there I was the
guy going hard by this point I've worked
my way up now I'm the chief marketing
officer of the company I own 10 of it
all just through Sweat Equity they made
good on their promise and
I was so broken inside and so unhappy
that I was like I have to leave I need
to go back to filmmaking I need to do
something that in an in and of itself
like I will love and be passionate about
and what I realized was the struggle is
guaranteed the success is not now at
that time I was a multi-millionaire on
paper but as you well know being rich on
paper is very different than having
money in your bank no doubt about it so
I was rich on paper I did not feel rich
and so I was like what am I doing all of
this for so my wife and I talk and I'm
like look I know I promise I would make
you rich and I swear to God I will one
day but I'm going to have to take a step
backwards first because I can't just
muscle through like this I'm I'm just
losing so many years of my life I need
to do something that if I'm going to
fail at least I'm going to fail loving
what I'm doing she was totally behind me
she said what are now famous words in
our marriage she said I bet on you
I was like that means a lot so I go in
and I quit and I said look here's your
Equity back I'm not going to cross the
finish line so I don't think I should
get anything for this so you know take
it and and do your thing and
I'm gonna go to Greece we're gonna move
to Greece and I'm going to write and
that's that and they said look we could
do this without you but we don't want to
and so what would it take for us to keep
working together and I laid out a plan
of if whatever I'm going to be doing
next it's got to be around value
creation it's got to be around passion
it's got to be something that we would
love every day even if we were failing I
want to build community I want to be
myself and I said look this thing that
we now call social media wasn't called
that back then but social media I think
is going to change everything what year
is that this is 20 2009 okay
so I'm like I think this is going to
change everything going to change the
way that people do business and actually
this probably was a little bit earlier
than that
um so the next company I want to be
transparent I want our real personality
personalities to shine through I want
people to see like we actually want good
things for them and so that for three
very different reasons became the core
of what we wanted to do and so we
founded Quest Nutrition everyone told us
we were crazy that we were leaving
technology like the place where people
actually get rich and going into food
the place where you're in manufacturing
is going to be small margins you guys
are never going to survive this and so
everyone thought we were dumb but our
thing was we're never going to make
decisions based on profitability again
we're going to be making it based on
like actually adding value to people's
lives being passionate about what we do
every day and loving our lives and so we
actually made a promise to each of us
and we said you're going to enjoy what
you do on a day-to-day basis simple as
and so if it's something weird like when
I started doing inside Quest
fine like even if it's not like we don't
see the immediate Roi in the business if
you love it and that's a part of what's
making you a complete and full human
being then let's do it and so we got
into really crazy stuff but ended up
being amazing
um because we made that promise to each
other so that was how all of that began
and then we just really lived up to it
about value creation about not just
trying to sell people on something about
building a real Community to uplift
people and it just so happened that we
had the right product at the right time
marketed in a totally new way because of
my background in film we were creating
all of our own content in-house we built
an entire Studio inside the company we
were shooting everything long before
that was like a thing it was like we
were doing that and everyone was like
this is crazy people don't have enough
rules in their life for themselves so
for instance I get out of bed in 10
minutes or less doesn't matter and I
don't want to that's why I have to rule
because I went Palace your mind
literally I went through a period where
I would lay in bed for three to four
hours a wash and shame and my inability
to get out of bed and it just
embarrassed me and so I felt badly about
myself so I wanted to make a change so I
knew that I needed a bright line so
bright line 10 minutes or less you get
out of bed as soon as you realize you're
awake that's it so and the rule is more
specific it's like I have to have had at
least five hours of sleep
um but once you put the rule in place
then you just live by it and that's how
you earn credibility like right now I
don't feel the way telling you that that
I want to feel this is a good moment
he's on my team I'm pointing at him this
is a good moment so I'm saying this and
I don't feel good about saying it why
because today I don't know what happened
I got out of bed in 11 minutes and I was
so literally time at oh yeah I mean from
waking up to actually physically getting
out of the bed correct my feet must be
on the floor and I must be standing up
before it ticks over into the 11th
minute and today I don't know what
happened I I was I was aware of the time
I knew I needed to get up and for
whatever reason one of the minutes just
went faster than I thought when I looked
back I was like damn it and so I'm
surprised you even made it here today
then right so now this comes into like
knowing how to handle something like
that like if you totally fall apart
because you don't live up to any rules
you're violating another one of my rules
which is don't do anything that doesn't
move you towards your goals so it's like
yes I've I it is a part of my identity
to confess this so because I'm talking
about it I want to say it now to an
audience it's the only thing that will
allow me to reset and be able to feel
good about it against because I don't
lie when I miss it I own it well look if
your biggest problem is it took you 11
minutes to get out of it sadly this is a
high quality product right yes very true
but my thing is people don't have the
rules and so I have other rules for
instance I wear a size 32 pant it's just
that's it and so no matter what your
waste is no no I won't let my waist get
out of line with that so I use the pants
as a way to guide now I would go down if
I got so lean that I was you know 31
that's not a problem but I'm not going
to allow myself to go up and it's super
tempting like especially around
Christmas I don't try to hold ABS
through the winter so during Christmas
like right now I do not have abs so and
I'm totally fine with that I switch a
different part of my mentality I during
the holidays my wife and I definitely
celebrate with food and it's amazing and
I love it the most so but if that
celebration took me up to like 32s don't
fit anymore I gotta cut back because I
have a rule so it's like that's how I
keep myself in a lane I keep myself from
getting into trouble I know the things
that I except for myself and what I
don't accept for myself and it's all
like stated it's very clear self-reward
and self-punishment is really really
important yes and you I think that if
people don't sort of automatically have
the guilty thing which they probably do
it's more a willingness to lean into
that and to say okay this is actually
going to serve me this is going to work
for me and I I actually do wonder
sometimes you know as somebody who now
basically has a profession of giving
advice at least on on the one side of
what I do and so I think a lot about
like who should actually take my advice
because my advice is not going to lead
to a Carefree Easy Life Lisa was just
saying she was laying in bed last night
thinking about me and she said how the F
does he do it because there's there's
just a level of things that I'm willing
to take on and I don't one I'm not even
sure it's healthy for me and two I'm
certainly not certain that it's healthy
for other people but what I do know is
that I have a level of thrill and
pleasure Obsession around it so for me
it's fun so when I think about the the
guilt or the momentary pain of something
up and you talk about me getting better
as a speaker it's like that journey is
it is a very simple Journey that
requires you though to really accept
that you're not very good at things
right now and that that's fine and so a
big key for me has always been to think
of my life not in the Len not the lens
of a moment and I used to tell this to
my employees all the time like stop
judging yourself through the lens of a
moment and start judging yourself
through the lens of 10 years if you
think of yourself in 10-year increments
like you will blow your mind so if
you're embarrassed today about where you
are don't compare yourself even to
yesterday which may not soothe that and
encourage you to push forward think back
10 years my gut instinct is unless
you've really been treading water in
which case then leverage that pain to
never do that again but if you think
back to where you were 10 years chances
are like you're going to be blown away
with how far you come and so then it's
like all right then I'm just going to
focus my gaze 10 years in the future and
start saying what would I have to do to
be somewhere where I'd be blown away
then with where I'm at now yeah but it
really does require you to say okay I'm
the The Pride that I'm going to
establish is actually around my
willingness to look at the fact that I'm
not good right now today if a meteorite
were to strike my wife and kill her I
wouldn't blame anybody but me that is
entirely my fault and I can back that up
because people like Tom it's so
ridiculous how could a meteorite
striking your wife and killing her be
your fault that's dumb luck Divine
Providence like fate whatever you want
to call it but Jesus man it's ridiculous
to blame yourself and then I point out
I'm on the board of the X prize at The X
prize there was a prize presented that
would allow us to track near-earth
objects better than we are today I voted
it down there because I don't think it
matters I don't think that the
likelihood is high enough but it's there
I know that there's an organization
right now that already trashed effects
near Earth objects I've never sent them
a dime of my money I've never called
them to encourage them I've never sent
them an email with ideas nothing now I
know all of this stuff exists and I do
nothing to stop it from happening so
the only thing that I can say if my wife
were killed by a meteorite is I did
nothing to stop it I could have made a
different decision and got a different
outcome I need to focus on that to
remind myself I can always make a change
I can always do something different and
get a different outcome so if you come
in and you disrupt my industry my first
thought is not the world what are
you doing this is so terrible and
Sinister we have to stop AI or whatever
my first reaction is how do I become
more adaptive
and people are putting so much energy
into thinking like I'm frail I'm weak I
have to be protected that they become
frail and weak when in reality they are
not my favorite quote on the planet is
Darwin is often misquoted as saying it's
the strongest of the species that
survive he did not say that what he
actually said was it's not the strongest
of the species that survive nor the most
intelligent but rather the most adaptive
to change that's how humans became the
apex predator we are the most adaptive
species on the planet you can take us
anywhere and we will Thrive and it is
that ability to adapt mentally and
physically that makes us amazing your
experience with all the you know
business experience that you've had the
books you've read the people that you've
spent time with what do you think is uh
the biggest
impediment to people waking up out of
this matrix-like existence that's so
easy for us to fall prey to
so I've had a realization recently that
I'm not an all Lanes driver there are
certain things I've spent so much time
thinking about that I'm very good at
answering questions and there are
certain things that I'm not so I'll give
you and answer that question from my
very specific
lens which is all about the person so I
think that if the things in the world
that scare me
the divisiveness scares me and when I
think about what is the individual's
creation of that divisiveness it is one
a desire to belong to a group intensely
a fear of being ridiculed or emotionally
ostracized and once we know that we have
this like sucking need to belong to be
respected to be liked you can really
begin to decide what are the things that
you want to be liked or respected for
and when those are things that you
respect yourself for then all of a
sudden it becomes very easy to do two
things to build something that is born
of connection Community kindness not
that you're not self
um selfish I'm very selfish it just so
happens that the more selfish I am the
more I like to connect and help other
people I am very much doing it for me
but it manifests in a way that is
Humanity neutral worst case and I think
Humanity plus ultimately so that that
starts with me having a growth mindset
so that you you want to see how you're
wrong that you can have these really
ferocious ideas but hold them Loosely
because the moment that your identity is
wrapped up in your ideas you are in real
trouble man your identity should be
wrapped up in your outcome what outcome
do you want and are you actually getting
that outcome and then as long as you're
not a sociopath with an ugly outcome
like people that get into identity
politics and things like that I'm going
to give them the benefit of the doubt
and say no for real the the world they
imagine is a beautiful world for the
people that they love and care about
okay fair enough so I'll just give them
that they're trying to do something
positive but when you look at the
outcome in terms of how it affects
everyone it starts to break down pretty
fast like that's where it really starts
to worry me so that to me says that your
identity is based on something that
isn't necessarily anti-fragile it's
probably based on something pretty
fragile so to use Naseem taleb's term
something that is fragile that's easy to
understand something that is
anti-fragile is isn't something that's
strong or resilient those are still
defined by the breaking point it's just
that their breaking point is far away
but ultimately even something that's
strong it's strong because you think wow
it can take a lot before it breaks
something that's anti-fragile on the
other hand actually grows stronger the
more that it's attacked so and that
doesn't mean you entrench in a position
that clearly everybody's saying like
this is crazy the only anti-fragile
position that I can think of is to be
that of the learner
that is truly anti-fragile so for
instance if you come at me and say that
I'm stupid be like amazing in what way
and the reason that I say amazing is
because I I know that skills made me
more powerful so you've just said that I
have a blind spot which means that I'm
less powerful than I could be and I'll
Define power because I think it weirds
some people out to me powerful just
means you can close your eyes imagine a
world a better world than the one that
we have today you can then open your
eyes and actually create that world so
that's the kind of power that I'm trying
to amass in my life the ability to
impact people at scale in a positive way
so if you're telling me that I'm less
powerful than I could be amazing I want
to know in what way because once I'm
aware of it then I can address it
because I know about myself that I'm
willing to accept that I'm inadequate
because I know that it's a temporary
state I'm not good at it yet if I decide
that it really does match with my goals
and what I want to do I can get good at
it so it's not ego damaging for you to
tell me that I've you know I'm not doing
something in a way that I could be could
be better cool tell me how when people
don't want to hear that it it's like uh
it's they're in a very brittle place
they're being backed into a corner and
people lash out and they're backed into
a corner so at an individual level I
would say to everybody if you feel that
you're blood boiling when somebody
challenges you if you feel like a caged
animal or like you're being backed into
a corner I promise you 100 it is not the
truth of the world it is that you have a
fragile something a fragile ego a
fragile belief system something in there
can break and because it can break
you're trying to protect it and the more
you try to protect it the more hardened
and
potentially violent vicious cruel
whatever that you may become so when it
isn't that and you're not afraid of that
thing breaking because you want to take
information in you want to assess it
doesn't mean you're going to agree you
may take that criticism and go I
actually don't think that's accurate but
I'm really grateful that you gave me
that piece of information and look
intention matters you can tell when
someone's just trying to be a dick so
it's like you've got to be cognizant
enough of that but when you get to that
point where you're you're leading with
everything is my fault including the way
this person is coming at me I've done
something to make them want to come at
me too hard or whatever you will only
ever get in your life what you
absolutely must have your absolute
Obsession so you that says your
obsessions become your possessions that
is so true and so getting people to
understand that that level of like I
must have this until it is that like
whatever it is if it's taking care of
your wife if it's doing something rad
for your mom if it's having a beach
house whatever it is until it you need
that like you need oxygen you won't get
it it is going to demand so much of you
you're gonna fall so many times there's
gonna be so many obstacles and unless it
must happen in your life one of them
will make you stop like you said you
can't be for sale like if your will can
be bought
it doesn't make you a bad person man it
really doesn't but if your will can be
bought you're just not gonna get it I am
Ultra ambitious and I told my wife the
only thing you can never ask me to give
up is ambition and
at the same time
my marriage is my highest priority it's
my highest value so I'm constantly
balancing the if she asked me to give up
my ambition or is she just reminding me
that we've hit a moment where I need to
put it first and I need to stop working
for a day or two days whatever and
really just give her my undivided
attention and as long as it doesn't feel
like she's actually asking me to get rid
of my ambition then it's like yeah of
course because that that is what I want
for myself it is the thing that's
brought me the most value in my life is
my marriage for sure where does that
ambition come from then I don't know
it's the one thing I wonder about in
terms of like okay we're not blank
slates was I just given ambition like at
a neurological level maybe certainly
possible I've made it bigger and more
all-consuming throughout my life that is
for sure I have just enough stubbornness
in me that growing up when people told
me I couldn't do something part of my
like every time someone told me I
couldn't do it I would say well I'm
going to do it bigger you you can't even
do this and let alone that and then I'm
gonna do this and you know we ultimately
get to I'm building the next Disney so
it's like so it's externally driven then
some of it for sure but some of it is
everything in my life is driven in by
how something makes me feel and I really
believe all you have in this world is
how you feel about yourself when you're
by yourself so in that dark quiet night
when you're all alone do you feel good
or not and so I steer by that and when I
start losing sleep because something is
stressing me out or I think I handled
something poorly I have to correct that
the number one question I get and I get
this question so much you can't imagine
how do I find my passion
the good news is
passion is not something that's handed
to you it is not a lightning bolt moment
it's another nice simple mathematical
equation first of all you need to
identify your areas of Interest
everybody's interested in something and
I find the big problem is people stop
themselves because they say yeah well
the thing that I'm interested in
couldn't possibly be a business so let's
take video games back in the 80s
back when everybody thought the video
games were a joke
you're ruining your brain it's like
intellectual candy kids get off the
computer go play outside Nintendo's a
joke it's ridiculous and then we have an
entire industry now that's born up
around video games that has made Untold
numbers of millionaires I met one of the
founders of Riot games that created
League of Legends the guy is like I
don't know 31 maybe younger I mean just
crazy they do a billion dollars a
billion dollars in revenue from
microtransactions
of things that are not essential to play
the game the game is totally free to
play you don't need to pay for anything
imagine that for a second you're in an
industry where they don't need to buy
anything to get full use of your game
and yet you do over a billion dollars in
Revenue because they said I love this I
like being around games I like the
competition of it I think it's amazing
I'm gonna find a way I'm gonna be
inventive I'm going to look for areas to
add value and so they have and more
people now watch Esports the finale of
League of Legends then watch the finales
I think of all major sports combined
it's crazy they fill arenas
it's absolutely Bonkers but that was
somebody who said this is something I
love it's something I want to be around
it is an area of interest and I don't
care if other people tell me that it
can't be a business it's what I want to
be around with enough ingenuity
and enough forethought into what
actually can be a business because some
things can't
you can really do something with
something that's an interest all right
so an interest you need to gain Mastery
in it during the process of gaining
Master you'll find out whether you
actually like that thing enough to
become great at it it is my belief
whatever it is you set out to do as a
business there should be one litmus test
you should be able to ask and
affirmatively answer the following
question do I want to know more about
this than anyone else in the world
don't get into something unless you plan
to be the best that's my piece of advice
I know that's not going to sit well with
everybody
but if you want to have the passion to
make something big to make big change
it's got to be something that you
believe in Beyond reasonable doubt it's
got to be something you've just got to
make happen
so ask yourself do I want to know more
about this than anyone else because
you're going to have to get better at it
than anyone else if you want to be
excellent and deliver on the promise all
right they're very concrete habits that
you can use that I have used once you
get your mind in the right place once
you believe that it can happen this is
what I did I worked out why because it
helped me gain control in my mind one it
was micro credibility with myself every
day I said I was going to do something I
did it two when you're suffering and
you're willing to fight through it you
tell yourself a story that you're
willing to pay the price to become what
you want to become and also and this may
be the most important reason each and
every one of you should start working
out and it has nothing to do with living
longer because we could get hit by a
meteorite who knows so I'm not even
worried about that but I am worried
about this
when you watch your body transform you
get the loudest signal from your
subconscious that you can change that
you can change anything you want that
you can change your bicep your tricep
your quad whatever it is you want
something that you literally could not
do the day before you can do today
and your mind sees that that's true
your mind sees that something you
couldn't pick up yesterday you can pick
up today and it begins to ask itself
well if that's possible then what else
is possible
now for me finding my Center was also a
very important thing so I work out first
the next thing I do without fail is
meditate
I do a just breathe meditation where I'm
simply trying to calm my mind
then I do what I call thinkitating
during meditating I get into an alpha
wave state brain pattern which enhances
creativity and unique connections I'm
not worried about whether I'll ever
think a unique thought I am simply
interested in the unique connections
that I will make that no one else before
me or after me will ever make because
their circumstances are different than
mine and that to me is what makes each
of us a beautiful snowflake is we're all
going to make connections that other
people might not make and so during
thinkitating I take advantage of a
problem I'm trying to solve I smash it
together with my Alpha wave state and I
see what comes out of it I read I read
obsessively
because I believe in one simple math
equation ideas in equal ideas out and
then I keep a list of the most important
things I'm trying to accomplish if
you're trying to become something you
need to know what that something is you
don't get skills because it looks good
on a resume
you get skills because it lets you do
the thing you want to do
so let's uh let's use Sports as an
example it's just all too easy not to
use it so
if you want you're in poverty and your
Lionel Messi and you realize actually I
think who's the other one Cristiano
Ronaldo thank you he was in the grips of
poverty and nice that's perfect so
Cristiano Ronaldo in the groups of
poverty realizes that playing soccer is
a way out for him and so he goes and
gets the skills why because if he can
win on the soccer field then he can
actually Elevate his family out of
poverty like when you see that trail it
goes back to the Nietzsche quote if you
have a why you can survive almost any
how so how am I going to get there the
the amount of work that Cristiano
Ronaldo has put in to become one of the
greatest if not the greatest football
player of all time is it's inhuman
anybody else would look at it and say
nope not willing to do that and fair
enough but it was somebody who said If I
gain these skills it will let me dribble
around people
score when other people can't score
Galvanize a team around me leverage it
to be wanted by teams to turn into
Financial Resources to make me famous so
that I can get brand deals and things
like that all the things that he would
need to do to pull himself out of
poverty like this stuff isn't an
accident it's about skill acquisition so
there's another kid that had the same
dream I'm gonna use soccer to get me out
of poverty and did nothing about it
therefore did not have the skills
therefore could not Elevate their family
out of poverty and looks at it like well
this is all circumstance it's not
circumstance it's cause and effect it's
how much energy do you put into actually
gaining the skills and did you gain them
or did you just put in the energy and
the effort thinking that should be
enough to gain it but you didn't
actually gain them so this is what it's
it's like the gift I want everybody to
receive is you can get good at anything
you set your mind to um
but do you actually set your mind to it
do you have that inhuman level of
follow-through do you keep pushing and
fighting long after it stopped being fun
deep into boredom because you have a why
you know why you're doing what you're
doing and you're just driving towards
that and when you have that you can
accomplish this extraordinary stuff but
I really think people now are doing it
for the gram you're doing it for the
gram you want to go to that thing and do
it because it's like oh this is going to
look good on my gram and look I've done
that a hundred times I get it but at the
core of my existence is not that at the
core of my existences I'm going to in
the amount of time that I have I'm going
to be acquiring skills I've always said
that the most Sinister thing about
excuses is that they're real like you
really do have reasons not to be
successful but now what like now what
now what are you gonna do like um I
remember I was giving a talk at Google
and one of the guys happened to be
African-American and he said Tom do you
think it's harder for me as a black
person in America to succeed and I said
that seems patently self-evident even
even just accepting that humans tend to
grab gravitate towards those that look
like them what I call the school of fish
phenomenon you always see the same kind
of fish with the same kind of fish so
being a minority just by definition is
going to make things harder if you
haven't read Angela Duckworth's book on
grit I highly recommend it it is amazing
I'll give you some of the key takeaways
the biggest part about grit is sustained
effort over time
if you lose interest quickly in
something
once or twice no big deal it is what it
is you realize that it wasn't your thing
but if you lose interest over and over
and over and over and over and you
always only enjoy the you know first six
months of a business and then you want
to move on you lose interest very
quickly you need to work on developing
your grit being able to sustain that
over time because building any business
you're going to encounter hard things
you need to be able to do those hard
things focusing on the hard things in
fact I try to start every day with one
of the hardest things to get it out of
the way to remind myself that I'm
willing to attack that all right you
want to be able to persist through
boredom and suffering I told you guys
that's one of my superpowers long after
everybody else gives up because they're
not having fun anymore I'm still there
banging away at it that's really really
important in order to create momentum to
keep things moving and to finally get
them across the Finish Line a lot of
people are able to get something to the
50-yard line or maybe even the one yard
line but they just can't quite push it
over the finish line and that is the
difference between somebody who's a
entrepreneur and somebody who ends up
being success successful the way that
they want they can get it across the
Finish Line all right learn to tell the
difference between a lack of grit and
genuine disinterest if you're not
interested in something you need to move
on quickly but like I said if that
becomes serial you may have a problem
and if you're only good in the beginning
that's the sign that you like read only
execution matters burn that into your
nervous system get a tattoo do whatever
you need to do to remind yourself
only execution matters
thinking about it feeling good about it
those are awesome but if you have a
vision of something you're trying to do
become whatever and you don't execute
against it and I don't need you to want
to build build a big business if you
tell me you want to be the greatest
parent of all time then I'm going to ask
you what are you doing to execute on
that goal
what are you doing how do you define it
what are your deliverables what are the
metrics by which you're judging yourself
and by the way if you don't want a grand
goal you don't need one but then say
what I'm trying to do is get centered
I'm trying to experience happiness even
that you can begin to look at ways that
you can improve that
now I very much subscribe to the theory
that the human animal is an active
species meaning it will forever be
moving forward I think that's a good
thing it's one of the most exciting
things in my life and I have three fears
one brain damage that freaks me out two
losing my wife because damn that woman's
cool and then three I don't ever want to
feel like I've hit the end of what I can
do I always want to feel like there's
something more that I can learn and grow
into what is that mindset of constantly
working on yourself without judging
yourself to a deeper level without doing
it in a way that always pulling you down
but always pushing you up and you're
doing that in your relationship whenever
I watch relationship Theory I think the
conversations you at least have
incredible so it seems like you're doing
in all areas of your life which era did
it start in which areas did it evolve to
let's just break that hole Yeah so let's
answer that question so where did it
start and where did it go so the honest
answer is that like many of the most
amazing things in my life they were born
of misery and I was deeply and
profoundly unhappy dissatisfied with who
I was what I was capable of where I was
in life all of it I was just really
unhappy about it now the one good thing
is I've always met things like that with
and what can I do and I have a bias
towards action and then I've cultivated
that biosaurus action which is how it's
gotten extreme and is permeated into
every area of my life okay so it starts
with it's this dark place this like I
said I failed in film school I didn't
fail in film school I graduated a second
in my class but there was a failure that
was so emotionally catastrophic that
everybody else would have been like oh
you gotta be like what's the problem
sure I gotta be in the class but I
didn't walk away with a thesis film that
I could use to get a job as a filmmaker
so for me it was like whoa I just lost
massively so I'm you know in this very
dark place I'm broke as the day is long
I can't afford Furniture I literally sit
on the floor in my unfurnished apartment
like that you know just it's a normal
phase that people go through but then
put but on top of that that I'm feeling
down and stuck like I don't know where
I'm gonna go
propensity towards action kicks in I
start reading I'm learning about the
brain figuring out how much of this can
I change I realize I can change it and
then that change felt so good and even
let's do a thought exercise this is for
people listening because you're already
there but for anybody listening and
you're listening to Jay because you want
to get there you see something which by
the way you feel when you're with him it
is real and I love that about you but
like this sense of Peace like the normal
slings and arrows of Life he's found a
way to deal with I won't say that he
doesn't have them but he's found a way
to deal with it and that's what you're
looking for so going into that it's like
if you are in a dark place and you hear
Change Is Real Change Is Possible
doesn't that lift your mood don't you
want that to be true and once you allow
it because you have to allow it once you
allow that to lift your mood you're like
I feel better just by thinking I can
change that was huge for me that was
like moment one was when I realized I
actually can change so this thing that
feels like a death threat this like
smothering cloud of just like despair it
can clear away and it immediately and
it's not like oh it went from gray skies
to blue skies it wasn't that immediate
but it was it literally immediately a
lighter load just because I realized I
can change so I was like whoa I can
change none of this is a death sentence
that's so like just amazing that was
enough to get me going and people are
always looking for how do I have that
energy I'm depressed I'm down on myself
how do I get the energy to push through
man you've got to find a way to find
energy in that you can change so
whatever position you're in right now
you can change no matter what it is no
matter how horrific no matter what
you've been through no matter what
you've done like there is a way way out
from under it but part of it is allowing
that sense of lightness to be there so I
allowed it the important thing here to
note is that everyone needs an ego
everyone needs self-esteem everyone
needs to feel good about themselves and
the crazy thing when you really stop and
think about suicide and this is a new
obsession of mine if you stop and think
about suicide what has happened
that person believes falsely
but they believe that they'll never be
happy again that they'll never feel good
about themselves again and that's why
it's referred to as a permanent solution
to a temporary problem
because that will pass
but in that moment it feels like it
couldn't ever go away
so we need to find things that make us
feel good about who we are because when
you lose a sense of feeling good about
who you are life truly feels hopeless so
that's critical and people often talk
about you know to stay away from an ego
to not pride yourself on things but I'm
telling you that person Prides
themselves on not having an ego
and so it becomes what you pride
yourself on is absolutely incredible now
don't make the mistake that I made I
used to want to be smart when I talked
about being the king of remedial jobs is
because I wanted to put myself in
situations where I was the smartest
person in the room
and in doing that I was always going
into smaller and smaller rooms
but it felt so good to be right and the
problem was I was wrong a lot of the
times now when this one finally came to
a head my business partners who were far
smarter than I am in terms of IQ
processing data
which I Define IQ as your ability to
process data rapidly they could process
data very rapidly
and we would get into arguments and I
would always lose it was very
frustrating and I remember one day
finally I actually convinced them to do
something my way and I realized
oh
I just won the argument but I know I'm
wrong
and so now what
I've gotten what I thought I wanted I
finally won this Victory I'm if I don't
feel smart myself at least I'm getting
reflected back to me that I've I've
solved the problem
and now I feel totally stuck because if
I really want to move towards my goal of
getting rich it does not help to do
things that I know are against the
company just to be right and in that
moment I realized what I had to do was
switch my self-esteem from being right
to pursuing the right answer faster than
anyone else and then putting energy
behind that and being like Oh my gosh
Timmy came up with the idea it was Sally
and Sally oh my gosh it's amazing and
giving them so much energy to try to see
it through because that's the right idea
and then I began to develop my
reputation of being the guy that even if
three seconds before that I'd been
fighting for another idea once I
realized I was wrong I would admit it
and it's amazing what reputation you can
build around that and it is way more
effective for business what is the
meditation uh process specifically look
like dead simple so I use a what I call
just breathe so it was born of Mark
Devine's box breathing at least he was
the one that introduced it to me so he
preaches do it four equal parts so
you've got the inhale is the exact same
length as the inhale hold exact same
length is the exhale exact same length
is the exhale hold now doing that made
me feel out of breath I just felt weird
so what I started doing was I'm going to
maximize the pleasure in each part of
the breath cycle so for me it happens to
be a sort of medium inhale a very short
inhale hold a rapid exhale I just let
the air out and then a very prolonged
exhale hole and that Rhythm feels
awesome and I do that for 10 or 15
minutes and I can get into an alpha wave
stay to feel calm creative it just feels
awesome that that's one of those things
that people that haven't tried
meditation or tried it but never got to
the part where it feels awesome
my heart breaks for them it is a tool I
rejected for so many years because it
felt um wussy to me and remember I'm the
guy that had to learn to toughen up so I
feared that that was like backwards
momentum and so finally when Mark Devine
looked at me and was basically like stop
being an idiot and try this and he's
like this tough ass Navy SEAL yeah I
thought I'm gonna try and then it
changed my life I switched my
self-esteem from being right and being
smart to being the learner who was
always willing to admit that he was
wrong identify the right answer give
credit to the person who thought of it
and put more energy behind it than
anyone else
and that became my driver now what did I
do with that driver
I turned that change in Attitude along
with my co-founders at Quest Nutrition
into building as Vision said the second
fastest growing company in North America
valued it over a billion dollars every
Financial dream I'd ever had in my life
come true
but at the end of the day the only thing
that mattered had nothing to do with the
money
and it had everything to do with we set
out to build a business around value
creation we set out to actively ask one
question what would we do and love every
day even if we were failing
and that for three very different
reasons ended up being attacking the
pandemic of the body
trying to help people live a more
beautiful life and there were times
where putting that Value First meant
that we did things that were less
profitable there were times where we put
that value first and it was outright
stressful to the company but that was
the driver and that was the thing that
actually allowed us to grow because
people could feel that this company was
different they could feel that we
weren't after the sale they could feel
what we wanted was to help
and in today's world leading with that
as you guys know if you're at this
conference
can have tremendous rewards if you're
trying to March down a path of
self-improvement without Clarity without
a terrifying level of clarity you're
never going to make it so start there
what do you want exactly what skill what
trait what ability what belief what what
are you trying to make yours so once you
identify that notice he did not say a
thing there
like you said right like you said what
ability what trait what quality you
didn't you didn't ever say what house
what color yeah right it's important
yeah because because I think that's too
much I mean when I remember first
getting yourself sorry to cut you off
please I'm saying this because I think
it's such an important point that you
made that you did not let that word even
come into a list and you named like
seven things and it didn't come in
because when I started self-improvement
so much of what I heard in the west was
always about a vision board of having
stuff and it was just like put a picture
of that ideal house put a picture of
that car and I've always struggled with
that always struggled with that being
the object of obsession so I'm glad you
didn't bring it up and you can carry on
or go on that or whatever yeah so well
part of it is because I certainly don't
want to be disingenuous like there are
also material things that I chase and
I'm inspired by and all that for sure I
just come at it from like what's the
skill that I'm gonna need even if that
ultimately is where I want to get it's
like all of that stuff people will find
and God I hope people have heard this a
thousand times it's so transient it is
never going to fulfill you right but
it's still fun go ahead Chase it have
fun like I get it
um but you will ultimately come back to
something more meaningful for sure so
the once you know what you want you have
that level of clarity now it's about
okay where am I in that and that's where
it requires that you have self-awareness
to know where you are in developing that
skill I love inspiration and motivation
but it is the neurological equivalent of
candy it's rad it has its place but
everyone because those just happen to be
fleeting neurological States yeah you
you just have to find something that's
way more grounded you need a mission you
need a grand why you need to know what
it is and and this is not a discovery
it's a thing you decide I decided now
because I tell it as a story people
think oh it was unavoidable he meets
this kid Rashaan and that coupled with
all the people that he worked with the
quest it's sort of inevitable that he
decides that he's going to
um build impact Theory and try to change
culture to give everyone an empowering
mindset yeah well literally a year
before I decided to found impact Theory
my mission in life was to end metabolic
disease so it's like you decide and then
you point yourself at something nothing
is ever going to feel right like this is
what I was put on Earth to do it won't
feel that way until about a year or two
years after you've been saying that's
what you're going to do that that's what
you're committed to and actually acting
in accordance with it and then you'll be
like yeah this actually is my mission be
transparent
it's a new world order man when I was
coming up you didn't be transparent you
put a marketing message out you spun
that
like you tried to be as close to the
truth as you could but you didn't worry
about transparency
but these days
consumers expect transparency they want
to know who you are they want to know
what you're doing they want to know what
it means to support you because it's not
enough that your product is good
they want to know that your company
stands for something
but it's also incredibly meaningful to
your employees
you want to keep top quality Talent
around for a long time
you want to make sure that they know
what's going on in the company somebody
that wants to completely transform who
they are you have to change your
identity so who am I I'm I'm the smart
guy and that's how I thought of myself
like I thought of myself as being smart
and then the life slapped me around and
I realized oh wow I'm really actually
not that smart I just grew up in a small
town and so in my small town I was smart
enough I was still never the smartest
but then I moved to LA and all of a
sudden people smarter than me were just
like growing on trees so I was like wow
I really don't feel smart anymore so
that was like a hard adjustment and so
then putting myself into these smaller
smaller rooms was the solution but
I realized that I had been sort of taken
as a default value intelligence maybe it
was the family I grew up in or the
movies I watched I don't know but I just
had this default that being smart was
the thing everyone should Chase and then
I realized oh I can actually change that
not everybody values themselves for that
and so I could swap that out with
something else and
I want people to understand that those
things that are just deeply within you
that seem as if they are innate human
qualities challenge them all some things
you won't be able to change but some
things are far more malleable than you
thought and a lot of what you value
comes down to what you repeat and so
just repeating myself I'm the learner
I'm the learner I'm the learner it began
to be my identity and then rewarding
myself emotionally when I did that
repeating it rewarding repeating
rewarding then it's like through that
repetition cycle it actually starts to
be meaningful the year the learner and
by the way I was telling everybody I'm
the learner I see myself as a learner
I'm the owner I'm the learner and
because I was telling people then I
really felt the sense of congruence with
wanting to act like the learner and so
when you say you're going to do
something and you do it you earn
self-credibility so now I've got this
Loop going I said I was a learner here I
am reading this book here I am being
willing to admit when I'm wrong seeking
out knowledge looking for disconfirming
evidence like I get to feel good about
myself for that fake this superhero Iron
Man the movie fan franchise is off the
charts and what is it at the same time
that you have people occupying Wall
Street you have them celebrating one of
the richest people on the planet why
because he dresses up like a superhero
and he tries to save the world
people don't mind money
people don't mind that you wanna
create a beautiful lifestyle for you and
your family they don't mind people
getting rich but they care a lot
about how you do it they care a lot
about what you do with it once you have
it
nobody likes Scrooge McDuck don't ever
leak a photo of you swimming in your
money
I promise it will not go well
but if you have a vision for how your
company could make the world a better
place and you use social media to allow
people to touch and be evangelized by
your brand if you're thinking how can I
make a product or a service that
actually makes the lives better of the
people that work at the company and the
people who buy the product if that's the
question that you're asking man they
will rally around you and we live in
this amazing time and you've got to take
advantage of that and it really freaks
me out when people think that we're like
either the social movement is cresting
or it's behind us it's only gaining
steam the TV's going away the mobile
phone is becoming the television like
these changes are a one-way ticket to
difference
I don't know exactly what it's going to
look like I just know it's not going to
stop and it sure as hell isn't going to
go in reverse only in the process of
gaining Mastery will you find passion so
to Me Passion comes out of it's kind of
like love I don't believe that love it
needs a different word unrequited love
is a very different neurological State
than reciprocal love so if you have
unrequited love to me that's something
you really like I love singing but I'm
at it so I have unrequited love I
love singing But singing does not love
me back now I could go down the process
of gaining Mastery and then I may find
that I have a real passion for it
because part of it's going to become oh
I'm gaining the skill and this skill of
singing allows me to have an emotional
impact not only on myself but on other
people I can make them feel good I can
change their mood I can tell a story
whatever it is that you want to do with
the music but when you're able to do
that and you're truly good at it and it
has the outcome that you desire then it
can become a passion but to get a
passion you've got to fight through just
ridiculous amounts of boredom fatigue
everything to truly become good enough
at it that it's a skill that has utility
people have got to reject this notion
that they have to be protected from the
outside and putting all their time and
energy into that be the change
you want to see in the world if you want
to see people strong enough to withhold
a better weight then don't worry about
trying to fix systems just get
tough watch how people respond to you
watch how your kids look up to you watch
how your family members look up to you
watch how people turn to you and want
help we have an innate desire to get
strong we don't have an innate desire to
have something else protect us all of us
if two buttons man one of them is you're
such a badass nothing can ever hurt you
you get it you know how to figure it out
you'll fight your way out of anything or
a magic fairy will follow behind you and
just waft things away
the terrifying thing is
this button the magic fairy is going to
get pressed a of a lot more than
this button but this button no one dies
of suicide with this button this button
mother race towards suicide and
depression and if you want to know why
we're having a pandemic of that and I
don't want to cheapen it because it's
largely microbiome and there's all kinds
of health things that are going on I'm
not taking that away but on the mental
side of what's driving a lot of people
not believing in that is we're just
culturally reinforcing that like we're
stuck we're trapped there's nothing we
can do that people don't understand the
Fulfillment has to be earned you can't
tell someone to just love themselves you
have to tell them how they earn
self-respect you have to tell them that
doing hardships that you don't want to
do and doing it anyway that's exactly
how you gain self-worth you can't just
tell someone to feel worthy and man I
want to more than the next person like I
I spend an inordinate amount of my time
every week talking to a camera
trying to help people to touch their
lives for real like my wife and I made
so much money we could have actually
bought an island and retired and never
worked again
but that's not what I want like I want
that fulfillment I want to do hardship I
want to touch people's lives I want to
lift them up I actually want to
transform and change them the single
most important part in learning to be
honest with yourself is to accept that
you must have self-esteem
and the problem is most people build
their self-esteem around something
stupid so most people build their
self-esteem around being right being
good being smart being worthy and they
see all of those as permanent traits and
so anything that challenges them being
smart which is my big one oh God even to
this day if I really want to get into a
bad place I'll just go hang around
people that are just legitimately
smarter than me and then focus on how
cool being smart is now I can be around
them when I value myself for being the
learner but the second I let myself slip
into just wanting to be cool for being
smart then being around those people is
like getting kicked in the face it sucks
man and so I had this I went through
this phase in my life that I call the
king of remedial jobs phase and I wanted
so this is post Film School post like
realizing that I don't have talent
I just need to be smart man I just need
to build myself back up by being smart
and so I would apply for jobs like I
worked I sold video games retail
um and I sold Insurance door to door I
did anything that I could where I knew
that the person interviewing me at some
point during the interview was gonna say
why are you applying for this job like
you're too smart for this and be like
I'm right where I need to be which is
crazy and sad but absolutely true and so
I did that for a couple years and in
that phase it was I just didn't want my
intelligence to be challenged so Flash
Forward now I'm working with these two
entrepreneurs they hire me as a
copywriter I'm in an entrepreneurial
environment for the first time and there
clearly smarter than me that that isn't
even Up For Debate and I'm
arguing with them for this idea because
I needed to win I just I couldn't take
another time where it's like they're
smarter than me they're smarter than me
so I was like all right I'm gonna win on
this idea and somewhere in the argument
I realized I was wrong and there was a
voice in my head screaming you're wrong
dude you are wrong you know you're wrong
shut up like stop pushing for this what
are you doing and I kept going and I
finally like whittled them down and they
finally just gave up and so they said
yep we'll do it your way fine whatever
and right then and there it's the one
time in my life that was truly a
lightning rod moment where my life can
be divided before and after and that
moment was realizing that I was telling
everybody that I wanted to get rich but
the way I was acting was like I just
wanted to feel smart and I thought hey
no judgment I'm totally cool whichever
it is like we can craft a life where
that would be wonderful so if what you
really want is to just be smart and to
feel smart all the time you have to quit
you've got to get out of this
environment because they make you feel
stupid all the time and that's not a
great place to be feeling badly about
yourself all the time for any reason
even if it's self-inflicted it's not a
bad scenario or it's not a good scenario
you've got to get out of it so I was
like okay so that's option one get out
of this scenario go back to being the
king of remedial jobs
or if you actually want to get rich
start acting in accordance with it start
making decisions based on that and so I
was like okay well I'm gonna have to
give up my self-esteem I'm gonna have to
like stop worrying about feeling good
about myself and I was like oh that is
clearly a losing proposition there is no
way to come in and feel horrible every
day and think that I will have the
energy to see this through so I was like
God what else could I do I was like well
I guess I could build my self-esteem
around something that is sort of
impervious to being around people that
are smarter than me and what would that
be being the learner and I thought okay
well I can choose to do that I could
choose to build my self-esteem around
being
not right but finding the right answer
not being smart but working hard to
learn and so that became just like the
core of my existence I decided in that
moment I'm going to start valuing myself
for how rapidly I can admit when I'm
wrong how much I learn how much time and
energy I put into learning and once I
switch that and I switch my identity and
my behaviors around to being the learner
then all of a sudden everything changed
and that's when I went on hockey stick
growth because all of a sudden if we
were arguing and I realized you were
right I'd be like dude he's right you're
totally right I see it oh my God thank
you so much and so I started earning a
reputation of I never just backed into a
corner I never argued for something just
because it was my idea I was
legitimately on the hunt to find the
right answer and so now I'm getting the
internal feedback of hey you said that
you were going to always focus on being
the learner you're doing it you said
you'd always admit when you're wrong and
I would try to shorten that timeline
down so I wasn't like taking an hour to
finally admit it or even three minutes
that I was trying to get to it like dude
if I realized I was wrong three sec it's
30 seconds Max like I'm you know just
finally saying it look you're totally
right I'm with you yep I see it and then
the world was like whoa working with
this guy is awesome he's not trying to
take credit for other people's ideas he
will change on what he was saying in a
heartbeat when he you know he fights for
what he believes in but the second you
can convince him he's convinced and then
he moves on and it just became a really
awesome environment the reason that
Quest went so fast wasn't just because
we had done something to our minds and
gotten to the point where we were so
angry that we were going to push us
forward no matter what
it was understanding the timing of the
marketplace and the technologies that
were emerging and the technology that
was emerging in 2009 when we first
started thinking about the company
everybody thought Facebook was a joke
everybody thought it was a huge
distraction and what we understood was
it was just a megaphone
we didn't pass judgment on it we just
knew it was a megaphone
and it was a free megaphone
and if we could give them reason to say
something good within a couple of
minutes of an interaction with us they
could have a global audience and tell
people about that
so we saw that the timing was right
there and we also understood that people
want to have impact how do you think
about failure then
um not trying for me like to not have
the audacious goal to not really give it
a real shot and I know I'm constantly
gut checking myself or am I playing at
building the next Disney or am I
actually building the next Disney that
means something to me so if I get to the
end of this and the world is clapping
for me and they're like oh my God you're
so amazing and look how far you went I
don't think people have researched
cognitive behavioral therapy nearly
enough pattern interrupting is like
everything get better at pattern
interrupting than LeBron is at shooting
like you just have to be a ninja like
you've got to be so hardcore you've got
to know about how to do that with
yourself so if I have a negative thought
that's recurring I just tell myself nope
you can't think this anymore so and
every time it will come up because I
can't stop myself from it popping up
into my conscious mind but you
absolutely can control how the next
thought goes the next thought can be oh
I'm here's what I'll do with a negative
thought that's so rad I'm so glad this
negative thought appeared in my mind
because that reminds me me to be
grateful for the fact that I'm friends
with Jay Shetty or that reminds me to be
grateful the fact I have a marriage that
is so insanely cool that like I
legitimately some days have to stop
myself from just curling up in a ball
with her and just chilling all
day like that is I'm super stoked even
now Jay it's so funny I had to stop and
think wait I'm going through this list
of things that I'm grateful for what
started this and I'm like oh yeah the
negative thought like that actually just
happened to me right now so you can
imagine in real life when like you train
yourself ah every time the negative
thought kicks up don't don't sit in the
emotion of the negativity that it will
bring instead use it as a habit Loop
trigger to think about something you're
grateful for and at first it feels so
awkward and it's like the negative
thought just keeps coming back but if
you're diligent and suddenly negative
thoughts become a habaloop trigger to
gratitude to positivity to repeating
your rules about I don't allow myself to
think things that tear me down so I'm
not going to think about that even just
saying that crowds out that thought and
telling other people that hey this is
what you're doing it is unbelievable but
this is why I'm I'm saying I'm literally
just the patchwork of all these like
tools and techniques that allow me to
protect myself from negative self-talk
from anxiety from depression I don't
think I've ever officially been in
depression but I've been super close
enough to know the feeling of staring
into the void which I don't think is
accurate it feels like the void is
collapsing in around you and just
everything is meaningless and it is all
utterly hopeless and I've had just
enough of a glimpse of how hopeless that
is to to get where people are in those
moments but anxiety that I've been in
the thick of so that one I know and I've
used CBT cognitive behavioral therapy to
do interrupts on that I have a very well
developed negative voice so I have had
to use tools and techniques to stop that
I never would have become a successful
entrepreneur if I couldn't learn to
self-soothe and at one point that was
what I would have said was my secret
power that my secret power in business
was I can self-soothe faster than
anybody else you're big on learning a
lot of skill sets right what would you
say has the highest what skill set has
the highest upside highest return
the the Baseline thing people have to
have is emotional resilience so you have
to and this to me is a skill you have to
learn how to emotionally recalibrate so
when I was the kid in the server room
and there was a whole bunch of people
farther ahead in their entrepreneurial
Journey than I and they all heard the
same message about you can be a partner
and none of them did anything with it I
started asking why aren't they doing
anything with it and I realized the
answer was I could self-soothe faster
than they could and so yeah it hurt when
I was told I was an idiot that really
sucked especially hearing it from
someone you really respect but
I decided to not spin out of control not
waste three days being hurt by it but
instead to re-center and just ask are
they right because if they're right
there's something to learn here and if
they're not right just move on and if
they are right learn the lesson and so I
just slowly started collecting it and
the lessons and the image I started
thinking was whenever somebody throws an
insult at you you have two options you
can let it hit you in the head or you
can raise your defenses and deflect it
and your defenses are the psychological
immune system they're real and I'm not
making that up so all of us have this
thing that comes to our Aid when
somebody says something that hurts you
then you're like oh well they're mean
anyway they're a jerk they're a bully
whatever I don't have to take them
seriously and so that makes you feel
better and you believe maybe that
they're being cosmically punished in
some way being a bully is its own
punishment and all that so and ah like
that allows you to relax and they've
done studies that show people with the
highest level of self-delusion are the
happiest so there really is something to
it but the people with the highest level
of self-delusion are usually not the
ones that go the farthest be because
they don't stop to recognize where they
really are to own the pain of that so I
thought okay instead of raising my
defenses I'm going to lower my defenses
I'm going to let that rock hit me in the
head because at my feet now is actually
a nugget of gold and I'm going to pick
up that nugget of gold and form of the
lesson that the person is throwing at me
and here's the thing to realize when
people really come at you they're really
trying to hurt you they have Sinister
intent they're going to come at you with
something that's true nobody comes at
you with the stuff that's not real
they're going to hit you with like the
thing that you're the most secure about
in the world so even the people the the
gravest of intent are the ones that are
giving you the most powerful gift
because you may be blind to it or maybe
you didn't want to acknowledge it but if
you can let it hit you as much as it
hurts then bend down pick it up and
learn from it now you can do something
if you want to see the recent one-on-one
interview I did with Tom bill you check
it out right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I was worth two
million dollars on paper and I'd never
been more unhappy in my life